i will get to gq
in the parking lot and then i will call
my manager and i will lie and tell him
to lie to gq and tell them that
i miss my flight or i'm in traffic so i
go get my chapstick
what's good gq it's your boy ddg and
these are my 10 essentials
[Music]
this is the number one necessity
money
making money is just
it's an everyday hustle everyday thing
how can i make more money how can i make
more money so
i feel like i've always been obsessed
with money it don't even be about the
money it's just about having the money
like even when i was a kid i used to
sell candy in high school like i used to
have my locker i had no books
mind you before i say i know books i was
valedictorian in high school 4.0
graduated top of my class let's get it
straight i'm not no dummy but
i kept the books in the book bag i kept
the snacks in the locker you come meet
me in my locker i go ahead and feed you
real quick you don't need 10 20 i leave
the school with like 100 a day
this essential right here is cologne
i prefer baccarat i like this brand i
like other brands and stuff like that
but i usually go for the high-end
cologne
because i like that high-end smell
my introduction to baccarat i think i
heard it in a song actually i ain't
gonna lie it just smelled like
money you know i liked it i like to
smell like
success
[Music]
the essential the big three
i like to go rose
or white
or plain
you know i don't believe in mixing
yellow gold and rose gold i feel like
that's weird
so i you know i i gotta have each color
ready you know what i'm saying i can't
throw this on with this cube
it's tacky you know what i'm saying you
can't do that so i like that
[Music]
plane is essential don't need that for
certain occasions i never looked at my
watch and said what's the time ever i i
wear my watch literally just for how it
looks
it's like it makes me feel like i'm
like i'm putting something on for real
you know
[Music]
i probably got about 30 pairs of these
i'm not gonna lie i probably lost
at minimum
10 pairs of airpods like i i've lost a
lot the main reason i smoke is be is to
listen to music especially in my airpods
it's just like you hear every drum here
every clap hear every snare you're
everything every lyric it all makes
sense when you got these in
[Music]
these are soupy black jeans slim fit i
probably got about
at minimum 20 pairs of these
minimal these go with every fit you know
if you don't know what to wear
i throw these on everybody that support
me know black pants i'm a big advocate
for that i believe in black pants the
patch say uh
royalty heroism
in the streets that's my first time ever
reading it actually i just know these is
these my go-to's man i love these pants
they stretchy that's what it is like
what i'm saying
so i ain't got to worry about
what i'm saying i can get into them easy
[Music]
this is another essential now i'm a
little lacking right now
you know you won't usually catch me with
the hands
you'll usually catch me with the i go h
m t
like 9.99 slim fits i go with a large
most of the time
but black tees is what i go with you
know you throw black tea on with with
the black sewies
i just go ahead throw these on look like
a brand new
luxurious outfit you know so it's like
you could just switch it up it's all
about the accessories when you wear all
black it's all about the shoes i can
make the shoe pop the color it's just a
different feeling when i got all black
on i know i know i'm gonna look good
it's a for sure thing
[Music]
damn this is for
smoking you know this is for um you know
california is legal i smoke for
beneficial reasons i smoke for thoughts
i smoke for a brainstorm like when i
smoke i come up with video ideas i come
up with music ideas i come up with this
and that you know what i'm saying my
brain just expands
[Music]
this is super necessary
i can't live life without chapstick i
don't know what it is i don't know if
people just got naturally moisturized
lips but i don't i just rock with the
gas station chapstick
you know i've been doing good i've been
keeping the chapstick on me i lose these
more than i lose my airpods but these
are much cheaper so i don't complain as
much
but
very necessary
[Music]
this right here is my baby this is um
more than the camera because my whole
family posts on youtube so you know it's
like that's the reason we're able to
even
live in l.a and have all these expensive
lifestyles is from
grinding on youtube i remember
my mom asked me she was like do you want
a car or do you want a camera that's
where i wanted the camera
and then probably like a week
after with that camera i got my first
viral video
cell phone when i say phone i got to
make sure
that i clarify i'm saying iphone like
no androids
not doing that when it comes to iphones
i feel like this is a necessity that
everybody should have it's made me more
successful i work a lot off on my phone
i even edit on my phone on snapchat
instagram everything tick tock you name
it
my whole life is on social media so
without a phone i'm really not
working so i kind of need it
this is
big essential my laptop this is where i
go to whether it's to edit
um i also engineer myself
so you know i record myself i got my
whole studio on this laptop it's a big
this is this is a bad boy my project is
dropping in august
and i engineered myself on the road
because i couldn't i wasn't able to go
to a studio at halftime so i go to my
hotel plug it all in
get all the stuff right over my laptop
set the mic up and record right in the
hotel room so i do everything on the
move thanks for watching i'm ddg and
these are my tin essentials